the ipad 8 is part of apple's newest
lineup of tablets for 2020. powered by
the a12 bionic chip it has a higher
performance compared to the 810 found in
the 7th generation ipad
and set to be apple's most advanced
entry level tablet yet what's up
everybody zaki here from geek culture
and this is the first looks and hands-on
of apple's newest tablet for 2020 the
8th generation ipad
the ipad is powered by the highly
advanced a12 bionic chip that brings
neural engine to the ipad for the first
time this brings 40 percent faster cpu
performance and twice the graphics
capability you can now power through
intensive photo editing motion tracking
in augmented reality higher series
performance and a whole lot more the six
core a12 processor also uses less
battery power to run tasks and has twice
the processing speed of the a10 lower
battery drain also means you can stay
out longer while working on the go
without ever having to lug around a
bulky charger with you coupled with this
thin and light design makes the ipad a
sleek and very portable device speaking
about the ipad 8 being a sleek and
portable device this only weighs around
490 grams and it's only about 8
millimeters thick
similar to its previous iterations the
ipad 8 will come with a stunning 10.2
inch retina multi-touch display
the screen has a consistent display and
allows great viewing from all angles
with little to no color degradation
on the interface there are new sidebars
for many apps including photos and files
and streamline toolbars that consolidate
controls into a single place
moreover with touch id you can easily
unlock your ipad with tap of your finger
which ensures that your information is
kept safe and secure in terms of input
and output we still see the same sim
card tray slot
the up and down volume buttons the power
button or the sleep button if you will
and of course we still see the same
lightning port
as well as a 3.5 mm headphone jack apple
is of course known for the cameras and
the ipad 8 still follows through with
his built-in facetime hd camera and its
rear 8 megapixel camera for snapping
photos and experiencing augmented
reality or ar so you will still be able
to facetime skype and take videos as
well snap amazing photos
and basically what the camera should be
doing
of course with the new ipad there is the
apple ios 14 which will be made
available for all supported ipad models
the new ipad offers new ways to work
with handwritten notes
and it's still perfect for note taking
drawing sketching designing marking up
documents and a slew of other ways you
can use this thingamajiggy so with the
ipad os 14 it further integrates the
apple pencil
into the experience for more improved
note-taking capabilities
how about that
phone note taking with the ipad smart
selection allows for handwritten text to
be easily selected
cut and pasted into another document as
typed text you can even draw
geometrically perfect circles and
squares while note-taking with shape
recognition for your diagrams and
illustrations in notes
for the environmentally conscious the
eighth generation ipad is designed with
100 recycled aluminum and tin and the
wood fire packaging
comes from responsibly managed forests
so
yeah
good guy apple if you can't wait to get
your hands on the new ipad 8 the colors
available are space gray silver and gold
finishes
in either 32 gigabytes or 128 gigabytes
configuration prices start from 499
singapore dollars for the wi-fi model
and 699 singapore dollars for the wi-fi
and cellular model and if you haven't
gotten one the apple pencil is sold
separately at 138 singapore dollars
these smart keyboard for ipad can also
be purchased separately at 239 singapore
dollars with layouts for over 30
languages such as simplified chinese
french german japanese and asparal
so with that being said apple has
definitely take a huge step forward in
improving their tablets inside out well
that's it for this video if you like
what you see don't forget to give us a
thumbs up and share this video with all
your bunchy goody friends if you haven't
already do consider subscribing and
smash that notification bell icon so you
can stay updated to our latest geeky
news and tidbits
until then this is zeki signing off
wahoo
[Music]
you